the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jason and
Lisa are with us hey guys how are you
welcome where are you guys from
Oklahoma City awesome welcome to
Nashville now who's the tribe the kiddos
here what ages and names so this is
Joshua and he's 13 mm-hmm Benjamin's 11
Sam is 9 Addie's is 7 and then Ruby is 3
ah and they're holding up stickers yeah
we like the idea of your gizelle focus
and so to help us get debt-free we made
a chart and so we could have gizelle run
and not get eaten so any day that we
didn't live by budget we got eaten and
we couldn't put a sticker up oh so we
all took turns doing the stickers so
none of us me and Jason didn't want to
ever not go on budget until the kids we
couldn't do a sticker yeah that's that's
pretty healthy accountability right
there so that's a lot of days that you
got a sticker yeah every single day a
bunch of days huh how much debt have you
paid off $77,000 and our goal was 9
months and we did an eight hahaha that's
what stickers do and your household
income during that time at range about a
hundred thousand about 100k cool what do
y'all do for a living
engineering okay and I stay at home I
think it's awesome very cool good okay
so we got an engineering which they're
kind of known for doing details maybe
and so tell me the story what happened a
year ago or so that caused you guys to
buckle down now and say alright we're
gonna get serious
we got to get rid of this debt well one
of the best wedding presents we ever got
was financial peace and it took us six
years we did it kind of off and on but
then we started looking at our kids and
starting to stress about college and
food when they're in high school Church
missions all that stuff and we got tired
of being stressed out and so does that
now's the time to get serious about our
finances so we can do that fun stuff
very cool okay yeah it's one of those
we've been I don't know blessed to kind
of follow that to the most part but they
knows that last the house and we just
kind of well I'll admit I've been
dragging my feet of like well we can go
ahead and keep that everything else is
good and so this was the home mortgage
yes Wow our house you
house is paid for how weird are you
totally weird I love it
what's this house worth about 250,000 in
Oklahoma City that's a nice hole very
nice home
very well done you guys you're young
with a paid-for house yeah wacky I love
it I forgot to ask what kind of debt it
was that changes the story a little bit
still very impressive so you were you're
going along you're going pretty good
really you got your act together you
don't have any debt you got an emergency
fund but that last step of putting the
punch in the face on the house and like
you said you're dragging your feet a
little huh yeah and then you look around
go these kids are gonna grow up I want
this thing paid for yeah when I read
finance or the Total Money Makeover and
I was gung-ho but I knew Jason wouldn't
unless I showed him the numbers so I
went through and did a spreadsheet and
presented him a good showing to the
engineers that's I knew what I had to do
so once he thought he's like let's do it
that's his love language spreadsheets
yeah very good very cool well
congratulations you guys very good okay
so it's a little different in that you
were going along you went through
financial peace everything's going
pretty good but that last baby step you
took a little like you had to push to
the finish line you looked up and saw it
you know we can get there we got to
reach over and smack it so talk to that
family that's gone through Financial
Peace University four million people
have gone through it and they never
finished up they never paid off their
house well part of it is as we sat down
and Jason I knew we couldn't do it by
ourselves it's too easy to justify oh
but we really want this where you want
to do that so we sat down with the kids
and said this is our plan but we've got
to cut our budget so what are we gonna
do in the kids vota to cut down our
Christmas budget birthdays budget eating
out budget whoa we did our grocery of
$400 a month while we are doing it so
for a family of seven whoa so they were
totally committed so that held us no way
my family is seven for $400 lots of rice
and beans and you are the whole you're
the coupon queen this without a doubt
yeah and seriously what did you eat rice
and beans
and for real not metaphor know that and
cheap cereal so we did lots of sales
sales shopping a lot you got the
bargains yeah yeah wow that's impressive
yeah and you only do eight months yeah
yeah I mean that's a long time that's a
lot of cereal but yeah yeah I mean that
you may never one eat cereal again but
now yeah Oh what so it's cheap yeah no
question about it but you paid for
$250,000 house we do and you got these
kids coming up on school and you got a
good income and you can do whatever you
want to do now I can congratulations
Thank You congratulations so what is the
secret to being out of debt
what do you could blame it on cut it you
got there by involved you got the budget
what else stayed committed and the kids
it was really the kids that kept us too
I mean we have to give them a lot of
credit because we would go shopping and
they're like what envelope is this
coming out of whoa and so I had and is
this going on
you know them being five little anchors
weighing down the ship they were five
motors pushing the boat when they are we
gonna get eaten today if we get this and
we did not want to say yes I love it
that's fabulous great stickers that's a
good plan mom dad way to go very good
stuff all right Jason and Lisa
Joshua Benjamin Sam Eddie and Ruby
that's right count it down $77,000 paid
off in eight months that's their house
and everything by the way making a
hundred thousand a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
yeah well Kahn you guys very very well
done that is how you do it man
fabulous absolutely fabulous hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind